I'm 20
My parents are like...so...
- Overbearing?- Yeah
And like, I wanna go out
And like, I wanna move on
So, can you afford it?
Uh, no
I'm immigrant
I got it
Yeah, and, it's really hard for me
Like, I literally dropped out of college
Yes
I have no money
Um, oh my god...
Listen
There's good news
First of all, you're 20
- You're a baby
- Sometimes I feel like my life is nothing
I look at my future
And it's like, I don't got nothing
You're crazy. You're wrong
You're wrong
You're 20
Which means you have 80 years to live
80, right?
Number 2, You're in America
Like, your future...
You're listening to the wrong voices
You're looking at what's in front of you right now
College doesn't mean shit
College doesn't mean SHIT
So I don't give a fuck
that you dropped out of college
I think it's good that you dropped out of college
You need to...
If you think your life is shit
Your life is shit
Keep listening to more of my content
You need fucking positivity
coming through your ears
When fucking all that negativities
come into your head
Put your fucking headphones in
and listen to positivity
And go get a job and start saving money
I'm trying to, but it's really hard
Right now, like,
I mean I'm in a medical situation
- and all that stuff...  - Okay, I understand
And, yeah, I mean...
We're here, like...I'm getting a job
Listen, there's always gonna be tough times
There's always gonna be tough times
It's just a little part of your life
This is only a couple years of your life
One year, two years, three years
It's a small part of your life
You're gonna be 25 one day
You're gonna be 30 one day
You're gonna be 35 one day
You're a fucking baby
Everything can go wrong for the next 6 years
Everything
And you'll still be a baby
That's real
It doesn't feel real when you're 20
But it's fucking real
That's the truth
OK
And once you understand that
All of a sudden you can start taking the baby steps
to fucking do something
Put positivity in your ears
Not just me, whatever. I don't care
Music or...whatever
But put positivity in your ears
That negativity that you're hearing
You gotta get that the fuck out of your life
If you can't move out yet
Put shit in your ears
You walk in, put the fucking headphones on
In your house, close your door and fucking listen
That's the game
Thank you
You're welcome
Listen
You're in control
Not your medical condition
Not your parents
Not America
Not immigration
You're in control
That's the truth